Why don't you like the liquid ionic minerals? Some people on Instagram say that they are the best.
Some people on Facebook and Instagram say all sorts of things. So, first of all, don't believe everything you say.
Don't believe everything you hear people say. Don't believe everything I say.
So, but unless you're given a solid reason. So, let's think about it. So, the liquid ionic minerals.
And will also lump into that category poorly chelated minerals like calcium carbonate.
So, liquid ionic minerals and earth minerals. Actually, there's a brand called earth minerals, which is just really cool, cool hearty.
I don't know how to say it nicely on the say it's really stupid because it's because that's how we're supposed to eat our minerals.
That's not how we're supposed to get minerals. We don't suck on a rock to get our minerals.
So, I just put this together. There's minerals in soil. So, you get minerals in soil.
How do you get minerals from the soil into our body? So, there's earth minerals, ionic minerals in the soil in water.
And this is my argument against people will say, oh, you shouldn't use distilled water or reverse osmosis water because it's dead water. It doesn't have any minerals.
You're not drinking water to get these earth minerals. Those earth minerals are not even good for you.
You don't absorb them. They actually take up absorption sites from minerals that you would get from your food. So, your vegetables and plant animals that eat vegetables.
A.K.A. cows eat vegetables and they're eating vegetables that have taken minerals from the soil and changed them into a double bond amino acid key light.
So, that double bonded amino acid key light mineral is how we then eat minerals. So, we eat our vegetables and we eat our good grass fed meat.
And it has double bonded keylated amino acid keylated minerals that we eat.
That's how we're able to absorb minerals and utilize minerals in the cell.
So, not only does it need to be in a double bonded to an amino acid key light to be absorbed through the gut wall, but it needs to be in that form to be absorbed through the cell membrane into the cell in order to be utilized best.
So, you could bond it to different amino acids to get different benefits. And you see that a lot with different magnesium blends.
But, you're getting your minerals through they're still double bonded to an amino acid.
And that's that's why I'm against liquid ionic minerals. That's why I'm against poorly keylated minerals like calcium carbonate calcium carbonate is just limestone.
That's an earth bound mineral. You don't get benefit from it. It can damage your gut. And if you do absorb it.
And the reason why you would absorb it is if you have a leaky gut issue, which most people do. So you have a damage gut. So things get across that shouldn't get across the absorb calcium carbonate.
And it will oftentimes be deposited at ligament to sites causing ligament to arthritis.
So, um, degenerative arthritis leads to that also poorly for poorly tillated calcium gets deposited in the arteries causing early athlete of sclerosis.
It's just they're just dangerous minerals. I'm totally against the liquid ionic minerals. It just does not it's not how we're supposed to eat our minerals.
So you either buy minerals that are just food based minerals. So it's just food based vitamins.
But they're hard to come by. They're not always easily found in a multi mineral complex because different foods have different minerals.
Um, or there's two companies, one tracks and one called Albion that make these double bonded amino acid keylates and then sell them. They don't have their, they don't sell their own vitamin lines. They sell them to good supplement companies.
So like our clear multiband is a tracks Albion product that is an organic mineral amino acid key link. So really, really important.